good ira jimmy is this perhaps the
quintessential heat box score
your team doesn't even have the leading
scorer you have five guys
in six guys and double figures all
within five points of each other
you've taught us all season it doesn't
have to be about you it doesn't have to
be about one guy
how rewarding is it to close out a
series with this kind of
everyone involved performance we love it
that way
it's a team game we've been that way all
year long
um but a win is a win and we take it how
we can get it we talked about one being
at the mud i think that this was the one
but so many guys stepped up for us in so
many ways you know
and i applaud everybody for being ready
tonight
and then just to talk to one guy in
particular because you're probably going
to talk about him anyway
20 year old tyler hero the minutes he
played the job he did the shots he made
he's not just your typical kid is he i
tell him that i tell you all that as
often as i can
he's a professional he's going to be in
this league for a very long time since
he's 20 years old
but he's just so comfortable so
confident
he plays with the swag that you think he
was going on 31 like me
and um we love them for that we wouldn't
change them
we want them to stay that exact same way
moving into the eastern carbon finals
tim reynolds jimmy those last three
words you said eastern conference finals
you've waited a long time
to get there what i i know that's not
the ultimate
destination of course but to be able to
say that you're in that route finally
what's it mean to you
it means a lot but like you said um
that's not my goal
that's not my guy's goals it's not the
organization's goal
we want to win here we want a
championship and i think that's what
we're focused on
these next eight are going to be much
harder than the previous eight we know
that
um but we're ready for and on the day
that
was a couple months after the train but
when they introduced you in miami
you said that this culture has always
spoken to you that you needed to know
what it was like
is it as good as you thought it was or
is it is it better yeah
it's better um like i always say
we just work here we're so honest with
one another
i mean if you watch the game you
constantly see guys going back and forth
um but nobody's taking it personally you
say what you have to say and you move on
from it
but that's what i love about this group
of guys is you know you can always be
honest from one another nobody's taking
anything personal no hard feelings
you know everybody works mike cugno
hey jimmy uh a lot of people would have
said that miami he had to play their
best
basketball to take out number one see
milwaukee bucks the team with yaz
antikoopa on it
do you guys feel you guys have played
your best basketball up to this point
i don't think so i don't think we played
a full 48 minute game yet
um and that's what's promising
as i know we do lock in and decide to
play from start to finish the way that
we're capable in the way we're supposed
to
i think the game will be a lot easier
but it's yet to happen
but we gotta have it happen in the next
clay ferraro hey jimmy congrats first
that shirt is awesome secondly uh
i think i know the answer to this but i
i have to ask is this any sort of
validation
to get to this point when you know so
many people question the move you leave
a team like philadelphia
um is this any sort of validation or are
you even
thinking about that at this point
i really don't you know you can't help
but to hear what people say
but uh that's what's wrong with the
world anyways people don't mind their
own business
everybody always got something to say
and you're right you know you have your
own opinion but
do what i think is best for me what's
best for these guys
and uh as long as i'm happy those guys
are happy i'm content
so i don't pay attention what anybody
says i just
try to live my life the best way i know
how vince goodwill
jimmy you've had some second-round
heartbreaks uh in chicago and in
philadelphia did you feel any
anxiousness
tonight yourself to try to get it done
it seemed like you were pressing a
little bit early and then sort of
settled down as the game got on
no i wouldn't say i was pressing i was
just turning the ball over
um trying to make the right play
throwing bad passes
uh it is what it is part of the game um
i definitely think i got to be better
because if i start that way
the game's normally going to start that
way
but no i wouldn't say i was pressing
playing the way i always play and then
uh it evened out in the end
nick friedel jimmy you've said all along
throughout the season you believe in the
culture you believe in in the players
within the group as you sit here now
heading into the eastern conference
finals
are you even a little surprised at how
quickly everything's come together
for this group this year not at all
um we're a close group um we like being
around one another
um we're constantly talking about how we
can make each other better
um and what we see out there on the
floor we just
we legit in it to win it like we don't
care about stats
we don't care about fame i don't care
about none of that all that we all care
about
is winning the championship and i'm
telling you that's why we're playing the
style of basketball we're playing right
now
rodrigo lazzarini live basketball brazil
hey jim on win and how confident you
are going now to the eastern conference
final
we're very confident um but we don't
want to be too confident we know
either way it goes we got a really good
team that we have to play against
but we still have to play our style of
basketball and focus in on us
and worry about them at the same time
but we're not discouraged we're not
scared
we're not running from any matchups and
i think that's what makes us
manolo rodriguez from tab to protest
thank you jimmy congrats on the win from
puerto rico here um
i want to know what are your feelings
because you have gone through a lot of
things
not only in your career but in your life
and now being in the bubble
there's a lot of time that you can
meditate on your past
and on your future and what you're doing
right now how it
impacts the kids i want you to give me
your thoughts on it
i don't worry too much about my past day
i'm sure i don't know where the future
holds
to the best of my ability i try to stay
in the now and try to enjoy
um the world that i'm in the life that
i'm able to live my family now
because none of that's promised tomorrow
um but i'm glad that i get to
do it with the group of guys that i have
with the coaching staff that we have
um these guys are all about the now too
we will embrace it
right now you know more about the future
andres lopez cultural sports
thank you uh jimmy at the very beginning
of the season i interviewed coach spo
and i asked him what he thought about
all those people that didn't see you
guys as a real championship contender
and he had a choice of words for me that
day in his response
today you have you guys have qualified
to the eastern conference finals
is it any and if it is how much of a
motivating factor is it for you guys to
prove all those people wrong out there
we we don't care we really don't
and more than us proving them wrong
we're just proving ourselves right
that's what it's all about everybody's
entitled to their own opinion that i've
already said
but we know what we've been doing day
after day
month after month all of that and we
like it that way
we want people to continue to count us
out and we're just going to keep moving
keep playing
on our best out of basketball and keep
being in miami
and last question david from la gazzetta
dello sport italy
hey jimmy looking at your team which is
the thing you're most proud of
uh in this series with milwaukee um
how comfortable everybody is at any
point in time in the game
how everybody knows what their role is
where they're supposed to be on the
floor
and what it takes to win i think we've
been working on that all year long
and it's um it's showing and you never
know what role you're gonna have
night in and night out like tyler didn't
know he was gonna have to play make and
make shots like he did but as soon as
coach said this is what you have to do
he was ready for it so that's what i'm
most proud